ساعات قليله قبل انتهاء الاسبوع الاول على
زلزال كرما مراش ويقترب عدد القتلى من 35
الفا في تركيا تقول اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه ان عدد القتلى وصل الى
29 الفا
ومياه وخمسه اشخاص واجري نحو 150 الف شخص
من المناطق المنكوبه
في الجانب السوري وصل عدد القتلى الى نحو
4500 بالاضافه الى الاف الاصابات ومع
تضاؤل فرص العثور على ناجين يتوقع يرتفع
عدد القتلى نظرا لوجود اعداد كبيره من
الضحايا تحت الانقاض
لكن ذلك لم يمنع من العثور على ناجينا بعد
كل هذه الايام وبعد سبعه ايام تمكنت فرق
الانقاذ في مدينه
هاتاي المنكوبه من انقاذ امراه مسنه بعد
152 ساعه وبعد 140 ساعه انتشلت فرق
الانقاذ الطفل حمزه ذات سبعه اشهر
الذي شاهدناه في المدن التركيه لا ينسحب
على المدن السوريه اذ تسابق فرق الانقاذ
في سوريا الزمن بامكانيات محدوده ويتضائل
الامل في العثور على ناجي